[Musik]
wie gerecht sind die korona hilfen
experten sagen dass die milliarden
zuschüsse in manchen fällen so großzügig
berechnet seien machtkampf in der afg
auf dem parteitag streiten anhänger und
gegner von afg chef morton um den kurs
und schwere unwetter in italien auf
sardinien kommen mehrere menschen in den
wassermassen ums leben
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers und nahm meine damen
und herren heute um 7 mit dem überblick
über diesen nachrichten sonntag
christian hat nachher den sport genau
mit bangen sekunden der formel 1 kommt
wir beginnen mit der diskussion um die
korona hilfen in deutschland darum wie
wirksam sie sind wie passgenau und auch
wie gerecht das arbeitgebernahe institut
der deutschen wirtschaft hat errechnet
dass manche der vom teilweisen shutdown
betroffenen firmen jetzt mehr geld
bekämen als wenn sie regulär geöffnet
hätten
viel sinnvoller sei eine berechnung
anhand von fixkosten die auch anfallen
wenn ein unternehmen nicht öffnen darf
mehr von thomas konsum leistende
adventszeit für hotels restaurants aber
wie in berlin bleiben viele lichter aus
nicht für immer so das ziel der
finanzhilfen 30 milliarden gibt der bund
eine um zehn milliarden zu üppige
bescherung sagt das institut der
deutschen wirtschaft es ist einfach der
situation geschuldet auch ganz schnell
eine lösung zu finden dass einige
unternehmen mehr geld verdienen als im
normalbetrieb das heißt also in der
summe zahlt der bund zu viel geld so
viele zu hohe krone helfen also eine zu
teure ungerechte unterstützung ihre
grundlage der netto umsatz vom vorjahr
75 prozent zahlt nun der staat jetzt die
crux ein geschlossenes unternehmen mit
wenig kosten bekommt mehr geld raus als
angeschlossenes unternehmen mit vielen
kosten genauer gerechter berechnen
dauert in der not zu lange das
gegenargument aber wie alles bezahlen
alte neue fronten in der koalition für
die spd steuersenkungen vom tisch im
gegenteil wir wollen auch das will ich
sagen dass die länder und gemeinden bei
der arbeit die sie zu leisten haben
unterstützt werden durch eine
vermögensbesteuerung der in deutschland
irgendwie abhanden gekommen ist wer
meint mit höheren steuern
das land quellen zu können der muss bei
uns mit widerstand rechnen das wollen
wir auf keinen fall mit niedrigeren
steuern stimulieren wie die wirtschaft
und bekommen am ende übrigens höhere
steuereinnahmen adventszeit krisenzeit
dieses hotel in stuttgart will zeigen
noch brennen die lichter und hier ist
der aktuelle stand bei denen durch tests
ermittelten corona zahlen
die sind am wochenende grundsätzlich
vergleichsweise niedrig auch weil
weniger daten übermittelt werden
das robert koch institut meldet 14 1611
neuinfektionen binnen eines tages im
vergleich zum vergangenen sonntag sind
das 1130 weniger 158 menschen sind
danach an oder mit dem virus gestorben
der afg parteitag an diesem wochenende
hat gezeigt wie zerrissen die partei ist
gestern hat der afg chef jörg merten den
extrem rechten teil seiner partei
frontal attackiert heute versuchten die
die er angegriffen hatte wiederum leuten
zu demontieren sie wollten dass der
parteitag dessen auftritt von gestern
missbilligt über die flügelkämpfe in der
afg jetzt nicole diekmann
auch heute geht es vor allem unten dabei
sollte es doch hier in kalkar um heidi
klum eine gruppe dirigierte beantragten
zitat spalterische gefahren zu
missbilligen
gestern hatte leuten in einer rede teile
seiner partei scharf angegriffen heute
dann eine hochemotionale debatte
er hat gesagt wir dürfen unser projekt
der partei nicht kaputt machen lassen
von wenigen querulanten spinnen
und karotten darum geht es und diese
rede ist nicht spalterisch sondern diese
rede drin für die große mehrheit unserer
bürgerlich freiheitlich konservativen
partei bedeuten die betreibe nach die
ist vorbei eine offene kampfansage
leuten aber ergreift das wort bleibt bei
seiner position
ich tue das wofür ich gewählt bin von
knapp 70 prozent der mitglieder in
fester fiel das sorgen dass nur wir hier
dieses land treffen können live turnier
und niemand sonst unlogisch
nach gut zwei stunden debatte wird der
antrag gegen leuten fall nur im saal
bekommt man das gefühl die fdp besteht
aus zwei ungefähr gleich großen lagern
die einander immer unversöhnlicher
gegenüberstehen die streitthemen
wechseln die polarisierung der partei
aber bleibt tief zerstritten geht die
afd
im superwahljahr 2021 der islamistische
terror fordert in westafrika immer mehr
opfer
in nigeria haben milizionäre ein
massaker angerichtet bewaffnete
überfielen ein dorf und töteten nach
uno-angaben mindestens 110 zivilisten an
dem tag hätte eine regionalwahl
stattfinden sollen
im osten nigerias ist die islamisten
gruppe boko haram aktiv zwei millionen
menschen sind in den letzten jahren vor
dem bürgerkrieg dort geflohen
trotz polizeigewalt in belarus gehen die
menschen weiter auf die straße und
fordern den rücktritt von präsident
alexander lukaschenko
dabei haben sie ihre taktik geändert wir
in minsk gibt es statt einer großen
viele kleine demonstrationen
das erschwert der polizei den zugriff
die ging aber auch heute wieder rabiat
gegen die protestierenden vor
es gab hunderte festnahmen wassermassen
in den straßen autos die im schlamm fest
stecken verzweifelte anwohner heftige
unwetter sind über den süden italiens
sind weggezogen auf sardinien sind drei
menschen ums leben gekommen
annette hilsenbeck berichtet die
schlammmassen haben alles unter sich
begraben
feuerwehrleute und helfer beginnen am
morgen die kleinstadt bitte im nordosten
sardiniens vom ballast zu befreien
suchen noch vermisste mindestens drei
menschen starben in den schlammfluten es
kam alles runter wir sind nach drinnen
geflohen
die erdmassen rutschten mit dem ganzen
wald von da oben bis zu uns im ort
die ganze stadt ist geschafft wir haben
so etwas noch nie gesehen
am tag strömen noch immer schlammigen
wassermassen durch den ort in der nacht
war die unwetterfront aus richtung
spanien gekommen
die sintflutartigen regenfälle
überschwemmten straßen rissen eine
brücke weg 13 mm regen sind innerhalb
von sechs stunden gefallen ich dass es
drei bis viermal mehr als beim
verheerenden unwetter dass es hier im
jahre 2013 gab also ein besonders
starkes auch über sizilien zog die
unwetterfront ein tornado und heftige
regenfälle sorgten nach catania für
erhebliche schäden
die bewohner fassungslos es gab starken
lärm nach fünf minuten war alles vom
wind weg auf sardinien gehen die
aufräumarbeiten in den nächsten tagen
weiter noch ist nicht abzusehen wie hoch
die schäden sind die beiden großen
kirchen in deutschland haben zu beginn
der adventszeit zur solidarität
aufgerufen
in speyer erinnerten gläubiger bei der
eröffnung der evangelischen
spendensammlung von brot für die welt
daran dass die pandemie kinder am
härtesten treffen bei der adveniat
weihnachtsaktion mahnten katholiken
nicht die armen weltweit zu vergessen
die den folgen der korona krise kaum
etwas entgegenzusetzen hätten
jetzt schauen wir in dieser sendung auf
den sonntag sport christian legt gleich
los mit der formel1 aufatmen beim großen
preis von bahrain
nachdem sich der franzose romain
grosjean nach einem schlimmen unfall zu
beginn bei dem sein bolide sofort feuer
fing aus den lodernden flammen retten
konnte ein fahrfehler von romain
grosjean löst das feuerinferno aus
sein hass ferrari kollidiert kurz mit
dem alfa theorie von daniil kvyat kracht
in die leitplanke und explodiert ein 27
sekündiger albtraum der vorderwagen
steckt tief in der leitplanke
gut 30 sekunden hält der feuerfesten
anzug rechtzeitig befreit grosjean sich
aus eigener kraft lebensrettend
sicherlich die schnelle hilfe und der
bügel der großchance kopf beim aufprall
in die leitplanke schützt mit leichten
verbrennungen am knöchel und händen
entkommt der feuerhölle seine
fahrerkollegen erleichtert auch darüber
lance stroll überschlägt sich im racing
point bleibt unverletzt
lewis hamilton gewinnt verlags dass
daten und der alex erben aber das ist
eher nebensache und sebastian vettel
über dreizehnter leverkusen und hertha
bsc trennen sich 0 zu 0 im ersten
sonntagsspiel der fußball-bundesliga
die bayer elf rückt dadurch auf tabellen
rang drei vor dortmund platz zwei und
drei für die kombinierer fabian rießle
und manuel faißt hinter norwegen softpro
beim weltcup in kuusamo ein höhepunkt
dieses langen winter sporttages markus
eisenbichler wieder mit top
platzierungen dritte springen dritter
podiumsplatz für den aktuell besten
deutschen skispringer nach siegen in den
ersten beiden weltcups heute platz zwei
der norweger halvard krone rüth überholt
eisenbichler im zweiten durchgang karl
geiger wird vierter pius paschke neunter
drei deutsche rodlerinnen vorne
die gesamtweltcupsiegerin der vor saison
julia taubitz gewinnt zum auftakt in
innsbruck auf den plätzen 2 und 3
natalie geisenberger und tatjana
eisberger für beide das erste rennen
nach ihrem baby pausen auch in der team
staffel mit taubitz felix loch und den
doppelsitzern eggert benecken heißt der
sieger deutschland
von francesco friedrich triumphierte
erneut im zweierbob
das sind dankeschön so jetzt noch
spektakuläre bilder vom himmel über
japan
dort raste eine sogenannte feuerkugel
richtung erde bevor sie in der
atmosphäre verglüht ist in dieser größe
und helligkeit sind meteore selten zu
sehen
umso schöner dass so viele kameras das
phänomen eingefangen haben immer wieder
aus einem neuen blickwinkel das wetter
noch trotz dichter wolken bleibt es im
nordosten morgen meist trocken sonst ist
es sonnig oder neblig-trüb
höchsttemperaturen zwischen minus eins
und plus sieben grad und am dienstag
gibt es auch schnee das heute-journal
guckt auf diesen tag und in die kommende
woche ab 21.45 mit marietta slomka
morgen freut sich hier die kollegin
petra gerster auf sie im namen des
gesamten teams der heute 19 danke für
großes interesse